hello welcome between
daily appointments for the online press and
live on obs today is
Thursday, October or November 26, by which
twenty six years already
I have a short announcement to make to you
before moving on to your questions and we
we are going to limit this
2010 meeting today to 30 minutes to make
room for the executive vice president,
madam vesta guerre, who will
present an antitrust case to you,
that's a 13th sandline topart hindi
or in the studio liverpool meeting the
president of pink charles  michel scott
in a number that uses in monza two cities
fight against govinden hamdani that it
saves things digital
transformation internally already has a challenge that
international cooperation between two
meetings indian verbal between almost
with these we can move on to your
questions and i start  with the ornais
cook press kit despite the gain
went to the estate we will continue to
work closely with friends consultation
crisis d  isent also propose dresden and
vary to the we welcome from albert the toasts
and only you despite his huge do
the noria of queen's facing albert
in spirit that would take effect the case here
all madrid fabio duarte
old financial law
our sorry we will  come back to you do
you speak english rigautou david because
being said yes thank you with them
only had your radical radio I wanted to
ask two things that are actually
related because it's on the question of
procedure at the border is  do you
accept the fact as it is written
in the letter in the document we are talking
here about a fixed to the irises so as not to
formally bring migrants into
the European union as
the four countries maintain is still on the
procedure  at the borders do you
recognize as someone
pointed out also in this
newsroom when the pack was presented that
the result one of the 1.1 effects of the ideas
and made possible is to create
great ca  mps at the external border of the
confirmed as is the case today
in the Greek islands
albert thank you david I think we
have already had the opportunity to explain these
questions in detail but just as a
reminder therefore concerning the question on
fiction  lloris is not a term that
we use in the pact but it is
correct that in our proposals there
are situations where people
are physically on European territory
but these people are not authorized
to enter the  European union or in
the member states and the procedures
that take place including the procedures at the
border at that time are intended to
determine their right of entry into the
territory
concerning
the places where
the border procedures should  take place at the
border or elsewhere we have the
pact do the proposals we have
made do not prescribe do not prescribe
exactly in what kind
of structure construction  s
these procedures must take place they
must take place in principle at the
border or in places close
to the border
but it is up to the member states to
put in place adequate structures
depending on what they
consider necessary  in the in the
implementation of these provisions,
but I would like to recall that 1 of the aims
of our proposals and to lead to
efficient and rapid procedures
which would also prevent clogging of
everything it is all these structures which
should  be set up at the
border
david a dirty web please because
after seeing the time we move on
to other topics is it
possible to
have open structures and with the
legal situation a few facts
reference therefore not being able to be anchored on
the territory
finally being on the territory but for
the power not to formally enter
the European union
the pact does not prescribe detention
as such so it will be  member states
to apply the the proposals
make it possible for member states
to apply grounds for
detention which are included
in the reception conditions directive
and it will then be up to member states to
determine in  each individual case
how to proceed thank you so i'll move on
now we'll end
on this on this topic moved on to
questions about skiing fabio let's see if
you solved his mic mic problem
good morning meeting
ok
[Music]
if a man  n a pas fini d action is by
its abily who lives lateral michaud you
if you and me if you can tell as if
commissions is the walking dead end at
two positions commissions on board
his fans what they deny christophe
richer series of
but at the end of a start stop system in
quarters and nichane drewbie possible
alcover a virginia fight you have a
question on this subject also to
hear there absolutely go hello yes
I imagine that madam me  rkel does very
well that it is a national competence
this is in fact still
publicly asked the
european union to settle this question
of the opening of ski resorts in
108 at its meeting yesterday with the länder
saying that  it was not worth being simple
how you why is she
doing this and how you receive
this request what can you do
or not do
thank you very much
virgil i think it is difficult
for us to say why or  to
give comments on the why of
comments of head of state I can
only reiterate what I have already said
is that these decisions are
decisions of national competences we
underline the fact of we insist on
the fact that it  must be very careful
to avoid a resurgence of the virus and
it is for this reason that we
ask member states to
coordinate their affairs well their efforts
take into account science and
direct lines  rices the
recommendations that we have established
that they are learning to establish thank you thank
you other questions for stéphane on
the ski season I see it's lorenzo
I think stéphane g not forget your
question but lorenzo you hear me
yes go  -yes the question of the question
is a little more in detail, that is to say
the problem is not for Italy at
least the problem is not to
relax the measures concerning the
ski resorts have made  italy does
not want us to start again
we have already had a problem
of contagion in the ski resorts in the past
so italy does not want to reopen the
ski resorts the problem for italy
is that the countries  neighbors austria
switzerland also france could not
let the ski resorts close and
therefore we would
have italians who go to austria or
france I don't know where beyond the
borders in the ski resorts which
have remained open and  after and
gravels in italy and so it risks
two counted and the Italians
would have turned while italy had
closed the ski resorts so the
problem is could we
have for example recommendations from the
commission that all those who all the
people who go to the resorts
skiing abroad either after being subject to
quarantine that there are measures to
precisely prevent this
contagion from returning while the
ski resorts whose countries have been
outdone and have remained closed but if
lorenzo  but as I said before the
measures that are taken by the
member states are half-measures of
national competences it is one thing
I still want to emphasize it
obviously we ask the
member states to take into consideration
the recommendations  that we have made
recommendations with regard to
physical distance for
example and to adapt its rules to the
epidemiological situation of each country
tries each country which must do this  tte
evaluation on the basis of this
recommendation to arrive at their
decisions secondly it is important
as also I have just explained that its
member states take their decisions
in good coordination with the others and
I think that I cannot add
many other things  on this point
thank you thank you
patricia you have a question on the same
subject we have a new day in day
you will have to test it is isabelle yes
hello I also have who am on the ski
is what in all the
recommendations you have made is  that
I don't have everything in mind in the details
on the way in which
confinement was needed all wrong remember that there were
specific texts also on the
recommendations for the different
economic sectors
is that there was a moment some
something specific about skiing first
question
and second then I understand that
it is a national skill but you
are making recommendations at this time
also on skills
national
is this a subject that can be
discussed in one of the forums going we know
that there are plenty of virtual meetings
etc
and if so which one I do not think to my
knowledge we have not established
specific recommendations on  the
ski area
we have established a whole series of
recommendations often of a
horizontal nature to ask to
recommend for example what rules to
respect in terms of distance the
wearing of masks non-pharmaceutical measures
etc.
so there is a whole series of
recommendations there which must  be
applied in each sector
by taking into account the specificities of
each sector
with regard to the forums that
exist louis certainly has forms
that exist for the member states to
discuss the
challenge of coordination, for example in
maine in the field of health  there is
the
security committee health security committee which is a committee which
is regularly agreed precisely in
the aim of bringing the
member states together to discuss the challenges of the
problems of the solutions of the approaches
in the field of health
thank you thank you
virginie you had a fire law yes I
would like to do on switzerland if in one
way or another it  there are
speakers because there I am still
on my subject which there are former
health coordination enhco in which
it participates as I do at all
that of Switzerland and the European Union
thank you the coordination mechanisms that
I have that  I establish also applies to
whom I presented also applies to the
Swiss raises what committees for
example there are also with which the
Swiss have access therefore there are
discussions with the Swiss if
with regard to  health questions
christian on the subject yes shone but has
like japan briefly as i called
miss the start maybe you
answered yes i apologize in advance
but in fact i still hear on
skiing from member states  res take
positions and in fact it is a
threatening position what is called the free
movement of schengen the swiss are
in schengen can a member state
decide as it was mentioned in
italy to say he is out of  question of
closing the border with switzerland because
we don't want our citizens ice kg
and in switzerland while we are closing
our winter sports resorts
same problem for france the
french are going to close access to launch at
their  winter sports resort
and can we prevent belgians
from crossing france to go to
switzerland what is being said what we risk not
letting go of you thank you thank you christian
that is the question that had been asked
by stéphane and on which we are
now going to come back to the bar
thank you very much it is a question which
is a bit between the
questions between the schengen rules therefore
concerning the internal borders and the
question of free movement which are
rather  with christian and the
justice team so if you don't mind
for a legal explanation
provided don't hesitate to
contact us both afterwards but
in general what I can what
I can maybe  remember and that from the
point of view of
internal border controls we are talking about
internal border controls
when measures are in place
which could lead to a refusal
to enter the territory
and when when this is not  the case
it is undoubtedly other measures which
are health measures at this
time and which are in the competence of
the Member States knowing also that there are
recommendations on this subject that
stéphane recalled earlier  and
then when when it comes to
questions concerning the admission of
European citizens to the territory
of another member state it is known there
are conditions which are defined in the
directive level circulation on
which  we could inform you
together with christian if if you
need details stéphane I think that
this must have answered your question but out of
courtesy I give you the floor or
captured a soldier
we know what it takes to be it
here is normal  question
what is it is there a concrete request from
the member states that you coordinate this
situation because well it remains to be seen
a cacophony that you have already had
that you are using what to repeat
is this  that there are data which which ten
years which say that what is
dangerous or is it not rather
the après ski let's say which is problematic
thank you
listening has there been
requests official requests  for us to
coordinate you heard the remarks of
virginie I do not know what is
official what is official what is
clear is that everyone knows very
well that the decision the decisions on
the opening or not have  ski
resorts
these decisions are sounds of  comes
under national jurisdiction and it is
completely different from what
Stephane was presenting on the podium
earlier, which is the role of the European Commission
with regard to the
recommendations that can be made
on the health measures to be taken
for a few  types of activities
whatsoever in order to ensure that these
can that the various and
varied activities can take place under appropriate
health security conditions
so there is a real
real difference between these two between
these two dimensions and I  I'm
certainly not going to start going
into detail here about what exact type of activity
is more dangerous than another
we have always said that it is up
to the eta member states to assess the
epidemiological situation on the basis of
all the criteria that  are in our
different recommendations
here we are going to close this chapter
here because we have two minutes left
so I close the season chapter of
ski and I open the questions
on other subjects for two three minutes
more raffut rave another
michel barnier stamp while jeans work
by michel barnier and waiting for the
resort is here is david thebault q the
floor today so if  you lose but
I'm going to pass the floor to oliver
hi everyone a small question
concerning the european civil servants
of the commission
is there any advice from the
commission for these civil servants
concerning the christmas holidays
advise you that we stay at home  house
that we do not go home to families as
almost everyone has to do in order
to control the virus is in addition
we should know what is the opinion of the
commission on the closure of
European schools until I think January 18
which  apparently a guy not bad
parents and also cause questions
about the management of the
holiday season for European civil servants
thank you thank you balazs yes hello olivier
oli  vier oliver therefore concerns the first
question the only advice we have for
our civil servants is to follow the
rules applicable in the
member states where they are and to no one
as you know it will be possible
for our employees to work
outside  from the place outside the place
of employment for a period of two
weeks from December 10
until the twenty-fourth of December 24,
so this is a completely
exceptional measure beyond which our
employees will be able to benefit for the
next two months  so the second
question on the echoes the other
European clubs so the principle remains that
measures always remain in line with
the applicable measures
the member states where the ecologists
are the detail more
I will have to look at these questions I came
back from the love of
bilaterally after thank you I'm going to take
one last question today
is husband grisel where the thank you very much
and listen it's on the relat  ions with
the United States and the businesses
because I followed with great interest
the intervention of many gentlemen that
they have European Parliament and I
discovered with a certain surprise ex
who are there I am not every day
that's what the first agreement in decades I
think he said to go towards
access taxes to the European market
it was an agreement on lobsters and
lobster beautiful I don't know if it will
help reduce its price slope before
Christmas for those who will be able to eat
but I would like to know why
exactly these products and by our
thank you very much thank you a question for
better we are there hello I would like to
confirm that there was this mini
agreement which was negotiated in August
which  covers oysters but which
also covers other products for the interest
of the european union happened are
covered the mfn way that means
it's open for all other countries
because mabhouh the united states lcm not
forward for  try to
find other agreements with the united states
thank you very much yum here we remain at
your disposal of course
outside the press room for all your
questions but we now give
the floor to the executive vice president
madame vesta guerre for a conference
release on an antitrust case thank you and see
you tomorrow